[Music]
probably one of the most violent
gruesome crime scenes I've seen in 35
years of service I saw everything from
pistol casings to rifle casings
I saw knives I saw a club it was just a
very violent crime scene there were
pools of blood there were streams of
blood there was blood splatter where
people were trying to leave the scene
that that were injured I called back
towards the freezers with a lot of the
waitresses and some other
it was really really scary we didn't
know somebody was gonna come back they
said people outside the doors had gun it
was scary a couple of my students - hey
weren't you going over to the Twin Peaks
I'm like yeah you don't want to go go
why a bunch of dead bodies